Michell is in Georgia hey Mitchell
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
Rachel me help hi dave was great to talk
to y'all you too what's up hey my wife
and I are in baby steps four five and
six and I just want to say thank you for
your help and showing us how to get
there but I'm gonna army and so my
income isn't affected by the coronavirus
my question is if we actually get thirty
four hundred dollars in a stimulus
package check what should we do with
that money should we walk it down the
baby steps or give it or just spend it
and put it back out into the economy
yeah I would I would say definitely walk
it through the baby steps I mean being
able to invest some extra right now is
great if you have the ability to and you
do because you have no debt and a fully
funded emergency fund so putting extra
money in the market right now it's not a
bad gig and then throwing some some more
at the house do you guys have kids yeah
we have two kids how old are they one
and three okay so yeah you got babies
and then do you have a college plan set
up for them we're just getting started
and this money would go really good into
that yeah
cuz that's where you are baby step force
your Doherty doing 15% I assume five is
kids college and you know you got babies
and you're just getting a set up and the
markets on sale right now but you know
the stock market is down it's a
wonderful time to buy and get your kids
college get that money working for you
for your kids college I think that's
perfect it's exactly what I would do
okay and take even I mean even a little
bit you asked about the give parts if
you want to give some of it yeah yeah
taking a small bit and finding something
right now to be able to give to I just
think that's so powerful we are
encouraging people past maybe step 3
this is something that you you you're in
a position to be able to give as well so
I wouldn't count that out completely
yeah I definitely mean we take income as
as evangelical Christians in our home
and we tithe on it anything that comes
our ways income and so to our local
church and if you're not doing that at
least take 10% of this then
and you know increase people's tips
somewhere or find somebody that's just
you know that's just gotten laid off and
pay their rent this month for them or
whatever that kind of a thing it depend
on what the rent is but you know I have
heard people weathers with the stimulus
check coming or just extra income ask
the question should I spend it to help
fuel the economy and yeah because he
asked you yeah he asked that that's my
patriotic that's not right the the thing
is if you are smart for your family and
you do something wise for your family
you have properly supported the United
States of America by taking care of your
family and so you're not required to go
buy a bunch of crap to say you were
patriotic that is no we're not going to
ever go there and not that Mitchell was
saying Matt I just I vouch to get that
on some other stimulus check that came
out I guess I was back in 2000 any
things yeah people are saying things I
feel a moral obligation to stimulate the
economy yeah right no I don't at all I'm
not worried about it believe me enough
of other people are gonna do that you
don't to worry about it you're
stimulating the economy about paying
cash for your kids college because you
fund their college fund it's just not
today's economy it's tomorrow's economy
so hey thanks for the call